[Applause]
[Music]
there are two countries in the world
that are often held up as examples of
what not to do two countries that for a
long time seemed able to conquer the
world but which have been undergoing
chronic crises for decades crises from
which they seem to not be able to escape
in which countries I'm talking about one
is Argentina that's easy the other is
18,000 kilometers away and is none other
than Japan of course this doesn't mean
that these two countries are the same
not at all the fact is that whenever a
developed country has problems Japan
always appears as an example of what not
to do
[Music]
[Applause]
europe's remedies for japanese ation
weak growth and slowing inflation could
have europeans afraid of repeating
japan's mistakes crabs folks the person
who experienced the most negative
aspects of japan's decline in recent
decades was emperor akihito
who abdicated the throne on April the
30th 2019
[Music]
[Applause]
allow me to explain Japan's emperor has
no real power and a ketose reign was a
particularly unlucky one when he came to
the throne in 1989 Japan seemed ready to
take on the world
that same year Japanese company Sony got
a major foothold in Hollywood by buying
Columbia Pictures Mitsubishi's real
estate division got the Rockefeller
Center itself Japanese companies were
investing everywhere and all four castes
indicated that the Japanese economy
would surpass even the US economy within
a few years however in just three years
everything fell apart
the Japanese model exploded and the
tokyo stock market collapsed and the
crisis spread throughout the japanese
financial system the years of strong
economic growth they had ended forever
since 1991 the average economic growth
has been only 0.9 percent a year
public debt has increased from fifty to
two hundred and thirty six percent of
the GDP it was China that snatched
second place and the largest economies
in the world Japanese companies lost
grounds and Japan was left out at the
top positions in the great internet
revolution
the cost of this decline strenuous
working hours of 12 hours a Morris store
common Japanese workers barely enjoyed
ten days of vacation a year and wages
are even lower than three decades ago in
real terms and that's not all the last
three decades haven't only been bad from
an economic point of view they have also
been very rocky in political terms Japan
has had 17 prime ministers from five
different political parties in the last
thirty years which is pretty insane and
as if this wasn't enough during Akihito
years the birthrate has been low which
has resulted in an aging population the
country has faced disasters such as the
tsunami and the Fukushima nuclear
accidents of 2011 not to mention the
North Korean threat
now you might understand why they say
that Emperor Akihito had bad luck but
hold on a second when we think of Japan
it's not just a crisis we think about as
manga sushi car brands like Toyotas so
well are things really that bad in Japan
what if I told you that things haven't
been as negative as they seem
what if Japan were somehow starting to
shine once again in this video we've
decided to look at someone Japan's best
features we're also gonna look at a
social revolution that is stealthily
taking place that could set a benchmark
or at least provide an experiments for
the rest of the world so listen up
[Music]
the best side van has been having a bad
time for three decades it's been stuck
in a kind of stagnation that it cannot
overcome yet despite this their numbers
are still pretty good
[Music]
obviously it won't surprise you when I
say that Japan is still a very wealthy
country we all know that but the
question is how rich or rather how
prosperous is the country of the Rising
Sun well folks we could say the Japan is
still one of the top 20 countries in the
world where households have the most
income after taxes with twenty eight
thousand six hundred and forty-one US
dollars Japan is at the level of
countries such as Denmark Finland or the
Netherlands and is above the United
Kingdom New Zealand and Ireland
[Music]
it's also one of the five or six
countries where on average families have
the most financial assets once their
debts have been deducted
[Music]
it also has one of the highest life
expectancies is one of these safest
countries and has one of the best
educational levels in the Pisa index
Japan is just behind Singapore in R&D
research and developments more than 150
billion u.s. dollars are invested every
year ranking them the third highest
country in terms of levels of spending
and the fifth highest when you compare
the amount spent to their GDP Japan
comes interest below South Korea Israel
Sweden and Taiwan and folks even though
they have the highest public debt in the
world no less than two hundred and
thirty seven percent of the GDP it
really isn't as serious as it seems
[Music]
the Japanese government has several
debts yes but it also has a lot of
financial assets and if you take these
into account its net debt is decreased
to only approximately a hundred and
fifty percent you should never only
count what you oh but also count what
you have
[Music]
and that's not all the government's main
creditor is the central bank which in a
way means that the entire debt has
already been shared among the Japanese
for the last three decades for example
with a lower financial return with a
good part of the capital going into
public hands due to the central bank
purchases of assets and with less real
wages in any case the entire debt is in
the hands of the Japanese so to speak
Japan has no external debt it isn't a
debtor in fact it's quite the opposite
Japan China and Germany world's top
creditors Japan kept its position as the
world's largest creditor nation for the
twenty second straight year last year
and unlike other countries their
companies aren't linked to the debt
either look no further the Tokyo stock
markets the fourth largest stock market
in the world where 60% of the companies
have no net debt seen this way in spite
of all of the country's problems because
they do have them things don't look so
bad do they
and what's more in recent years between
2007 and 2017 a curious development has
taken place you see the Japanese economy
is barely growing that's a fact but its
population is shrinking in this economy
has no inflation the real growth per
capita which ultimately determines the
level of well-being has risen to equal
the growth rate of the US and is ranked
above countries such as France and the
UK surprised well you shouldn't be
this has been largely driven by the
Asian continents economic explosion
afterall Japan has neighbors such as
China Vietnam and India where for
example Suzuki a Japanese car company
accounts for just over 50% of the entire
Indian car market we're talking about
billions of potential customers here
want another example well look at what
happens with tourism you see
traditionally japan has had very few
tourists mainly because of its distance
from other developed countries however
in recent years it's become quite the
theme-park
Japan has the largest growing tourist
rival rate in the world within a short
time that's largely thanks to Chinese
visitors the number of foreign tourists
has gone from just over 6 million in
2011 to over 31 million in 2018 and
forecasts say that this figure could
exceed 60 million by 2030
obviously all of this means a lot of new
jobs but its population is the oldest in
the world's and is in fact reducing
every year so how can they fill all of
these new positions role folks that's
where the sexual revolution promoted by
the prime minister shinzo our day comes
into play and listen up because Japan is
becoming an experiments on how to deal
with demographic ageing and I think
their solution is probably going to
surprise you
the social revolution okay something is
very clear for Japan in such an old
country where the population is expected
to decrease significantly during the
upcoming decades only productivity and
investment in technology and robots can
save them but dear viewer this takes
time and of course to be able to invest
as much as they need they have to become
a prosperous economy so the question is
how can a stagnating economy recover and
keep public finances under control while
the population ages at full speed
especially when you consider what an
aging population means in terms of
pensions and health spending
well the Prime Minister believes that
it's essential to increase latent
participation in the short-term raise
the percentage of people who work and
that's precisely what is happening in
Japan
[Music]
but have you noticed this how are they
managing to increase the number of
workers in a country if the population
is both shrinking and aging at a rapid
pace so what is Japan doing to solve
this problem
well folks the answer is that Shinzo Abe
a is leading a social revolution in
Japan obviously with less demanding jobs
and shorter shifts this has led to more
than Harville Japanese men aged between
65 and 70 going back to work this is
more than double the average in the OECD
countries which includes almost all of
the most developed countries have you
ever seen the movie the intern with the
Robert De Niro well it's kind of
something like that
[Music]
on the other hand the government is also
promoting a historic increase in female
labor participation which in Japan has
not traditionally been very high Japan
is experiencing a huge transformation
the number of women working and
occupying leadership positions is
growing this change has been driven by
what has become known as women anomic
s-- this is a policy that for example
has increased daycare services
incentivized part-time contracts and
encouraged companies to adjust their
schedules to the needs of women with
children this is an Japan has become one
of the countries with the greatest
percentage of working women today
however the truth is that despite all
these measures the Japanese economy
still needs many workers in fact there
are so many vacancies that there are
currently more than a hundred and fifty
jobs for every 100 candidates yep you
heard that right there are more jobs
available than candidates many more
that's why in recent years Shinzo Abe a
has been demolishing what has been for
so long a taboo in Japanese society
[Music]
the arrival of new blood
since time immemorial Japan has been one
of the country's most close to
immigration in the world we already
talked about this a while ago on visual
politic in Japan the immigrant
population accounts for only 1.8 percent
of the total this is one of the lowest
percentages if not the lowest percentage
in the entire developed world however as
changing Japan to Asia give us you're
young you're skilled you're eager
workers since Shinzo Abe a came to power
in 2012 the number of foreigners has
doubled and that won't be the end of it
in December 2018 Japan approved new laws
to boost the arrival of immigrants we
need to break free of conventional
thinking I will create a Japan that can
attract great talent from around the
world folks the new regulations make
allowances for two new statuses for the
foreign population on the one hand very
appealing status to attract the most
qualified workers who can settle in
Japan practically indefinitely with
their families on the other hands
there's a new status designed so
industries can bring in less qualified
workers here the conditions are more
limited but even so the new regulation
seeks to eliminate all the problems and
the bad conditions that these foreign
workers have typically suffered
something that we already talked about
in another video
[Music]
in any case folks Japan has many many
problems and we've talked about them
many times and we intend to do so in the
future but there are also reasons it can
remain one of the richest countries in
the world so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel it's
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]